hi my name is alicia pasquale pena and i
play aisha garcia
hi i'm josie toda and i play lexi haddad
hey i'm josquito velazquez and i play
daisy jimenez
hi i'm mitchell hogue i play mac morris
on say by the bell hi
i'm elizabeth berkeley lauren and i play
jesse spano hello everybody my name is
belmont camelli
and i play jamie spano what's up guys my
name is dexter darden and i play devonta
young hey i'm mario lopez and i play ac
slater from saved by the bell and today
we're with buzzfeed
take a little quiz and find out which
combination of classic
and new saved by the bell characters we
actually
are in real life
pick a 90s song our options are
baby one more time by britney spears
what's my
age again by blink182 no scrubs by tlc
dreaming of you by selena the boy is
mine by brandy and
monica and live in la vida loca by ricky
martin
i'ma go with the boy is mine mario that
is
not what i was expecting by you at all
don't be stereotyping me and thinking
i'm gonna go with
ricky martin or selena player honestly
it was about my age again by blink 182
because nobody
because you are the bionic human nobody
really knows
i'm gonna go with no scrubs no scrubs by
tlc just hit me at a time in my life
when they came out with that like
spandex black on and they had the little
red things around their hearts i was
just like whatever
chili left eye and tea boss got going on
i went part of it i don't think anything
beats
the whiny teenage angst of blink 182 so
i'm gonna go with what's my age again
but live in la vida loca by ricky martin
come on i got i gotta go with it's good
too my soul
is telling me britney spears because
she's
iconic i think that i'm gonna have to go
with the queen
one of the best vocalists brandy like
brandy monica like that song is come on
you do
it what's my age you're gonna say what's
my age oh he was gonna
say that i feel like i grew up on like
one of you two i'm gonna know scrubs
because you know i kind of jammed to
that a little
more than i should have but i do love me
some selena
pick a 90s icon to get into hijinks with
will smith jennifer aniston janet
jackson brad pitt
leonardo dicaprio or gwen stefani i love
me a young leo but gwen stefani seems
like she would be so fun to do a bunch
of stuff with
yeah i'm gonna go with gwen because i
mean all her music videos if you
actually see it she's doing a bunch of
reckless stuff
already so why not let's agree on that
i'm gonna have to go with janet she's
the queen i'm gonna have to go with will
smith
yeah anderson is like you can never get
in trouble with her i'm going my boy leo
cap
leo decap philadelphia i would be doing
my city and one of my biggest
inspirations of all time if i didn't say
will smith and honestly hi
jinx is right up will smith's alley so
i'm gonna go with will smith i think i'd
have to say
jennifer i think since it's hijinks you
gotta go will smith
pick a superlative that best fits you
best dressed
best eyes biggest life of the party
biggest overachiever
biggest flirt best personality i'm gonna
go with biggest flirt because i'll flirt
it up with anybody
i have two different colored eyes so
maybe that
it is an odd situation where my mom is
brown and my dad is green so maybe for
my parents i'll choose
i'll choose best eyes okay well you're
the biggest overachiever
i think anyone's ever met in their
entire life i'm going to say biggest
overachiever for me
and i think for you i don't know best
personality that's probably just a
privilege that people would give
me i feel like you would be either best
dressed
or biggest flirt yeah i feel like i
would have best personality right
i'm gonna go with best dressed just
because i feel like it's arrogant to say
best flirt i gotta say biggest life for
the party
that's my player that's what i do when
we step onto the scene we gotta bring
the smiles and the jokes
pick a nighties trend that has come back
in style we got adidas slides
baggy jeans mini backpacks bucket hats
high-waisted jeans or
cropped tees i guess if you have to pick
you got to do the adidas slides right
because they never left
me and you're on the same page again gee
like it's hard for me to pick adidas
slides because they never went
out of style but it's beyonce's
i'm a high-waisted jeans crop top kind
of girl like that's how i want to set
every day
crop teeth like how do i pick do a
cropped teeth i think you're right i
like a good adidas slide
right so i like the high-waisted jean
for guys i think i'm gonna go high which
is gene although i will say
i'm a proud owner of many crop tops and
i'm glad they're back in fashion
i would say more in my closet and really
like save the day
i'm gonna go with highway 2 jeans i'm
going to go with crop teas because
it's apparently all that i own pick
something you would order at the max
milkshake panini burger
chicken strips sundae or french fries i
would say the french fries for me when i
was actually in the max filming were a
staple
i'm gonna have to go with the fry i mean
not that you've been gone i don't know
if it's some sort of emotional thing but
now that you've been back home in new
york
i have eaten fries every night i said
milkshake
milkshakes my number two i gotta go
chicken strips only because like
it's actually mine i'm dying like a
diner
and i feel like diners always had the
fire chicken strips with the great honey
mustard on them so i'm going there
french fries because honestly when you
was hungry those fries
hit on yeah yeah i'm gonna do french
fries too i know you really want to know
this val
but when we would film the scenes back
in the day
i didn't want to eat french fries so
they did slice jicama
to look like fries i'm gonna go with the
panini just because i've never
known the max to actually have it and it
sounds good i think i'm gonna go with
the burger
because i am constantly hungry and i
think that's gonna allow me the most
calories
pick a 90s tv show you would want to see
rebooted
friends sister sister dawson's creek the
nanny
living single and buffy the vampire
slayer i want to see buffy the vampire
slay rebooted and i don't even want to
watch the original i just want to jump
into a reboot of it because it sounds
good
i would say dawson's creek i think that
they'd have a blast so
i'm going to do dawson's creek it's
sister sister for sure
i am living single one of the best shows
of all time
i feel like sister says i mean i know
i'm gonna just go with this this stuff
because i love that show
i'm gonna have to go with straight out
living single which is
two friends it was the original friends
friends friends that deserve to get more
love
lastly pick a random but classic og save
by the bell
episode house party no hope with dope
rock you mentary the last dance jessie's
song
and the bayside triangle i'm gonna go
with house parties yeah and house party
is like obviously one of the most iconic
episodes
let's do house party let's do house
party anything that has the word party
in it i'm all about especially a house
party because it reminds me of the movie
from back in the day
so i'm gonna go with house party house
party as well man kid and play
i feel like you're gonna go with house
party how'd you know you're wrong
yes you see i know you i'm gonna choose
jesse's song because i think now every
time i say i'm so excited the song just
plays in my head randomly
i'm sorry i have to pick jesse don't be
sorry no
that would be wrong and as my son how do
you not choose that well okay so here
i'm on the fence
between two here and i don't want you to
get mad at me because jesse's song
is a staple and i knew you were gonna
pick it but i think i'm gonna go with
house party
because i like watching mario dance
i got ac slater and aisha garcia
and i got jessie spano and devonta young
ah come on
about ourselves though i know jessie
spano kelly kapowski
daisy jimenez combo i got ac slater and
aisha garcia
jesse spano and devonte young ac slater
and aisha garcia i didn't think that i
would get devonte from the new cast
but i i've had an idea that i was gonna
get jessie from the original
i did not think i was gonna get daisy
jimenez
but i did kind of have an inkling that i
was going to get kelly capowski
time to get so excited because you are a
hard-working individual that inspires
everyone around you
but you probably already knew that
you're also someone that never backs
away from a new challenger experience
if ambition drive and determination were
something you could bottle and sell
you'd be a multi-millionaire and to top
it all off you're a compassionate person
that is always looking out for the ones
you love
hey mama you're most definitely someone
who loves nothing more than to tackle
challenges and you're not the type who
likes to sit around and wait for an
opportunity to come to you
you go out and seek it but you also tend
to always look out for the best interest
in your friends and family that's me in
real life we both got our own characters
which is great that means we're not far
from who we play on television
i think we both got both got pretty spot
on there i'm gonna screenshot this
you